The West Wing was evacuated on Sunday
after a bag of white powder was
discovered in the White House
the evacuation was brief however after
officials remembered that Hunter Biden
doesn't snort anthrax
as far as we know the white powder
turned out to be nothing more than a
first son favorite booger sugar you know
what I'm talking about some Colombian
nose candy if you catch my drift little
Yale College baking soda if you can
infer my meaning I'm talking about Coke
since the president's infamously
unrepentant dirt bag of a sun had been
visiting the White House that very
weekend A lot of people came to
conclusions about how the cocaine got
there MSNBC however is shocked